Thank You president Taurus welcome
Governor Patrick thank you everyone for
being here the hundred and forty sixth
annual meeting of the Harvard Alumni
Association at the three hundred and
sixty fourth commencement of Harvard
University it's a particular pleasure to
welcome former governor Deval Patrick of
the college class of 1978 and the
Harvard Law School class of 1982
throughout his distinguished career in
government he forcefully argued for the
power of Education to transform lives
nothing made that case more persuasively
than his own remarkable life from
Chicago's South Side to the
Massachusetts Statehouse when he was
sworn in as governor he took the oath of
office with the Mende Bible presented in
1841 by the African captives who had
seized the slave ship Amistad - the man
who had won their legal right to freedom
John Quincy Adams Governor Patrick can
claim connection with both the African
heritage of the Amistad rebels and the
institutional roots of their defender
Adams as you heard before from president
Torres was a member of the Harvard
College class of 1787 and was both the
first president of this Alumni
Association and himself the son of an
earlier alumnus John Adams of the class
of 1755 that kind of continuity across
the centuries is not the least of the
reasons that we congregate here every
spring to renew and reinforce our ties
to this extraordinary play
let me start by noticing what is both
obvious and curious we are here today
together we are here in association it's
an association of many people and many
generations we celebrate a connection
across time in these festival rites
singing our alma mater adorning
ourselves in medieval robes to mark the
deep-rooted traditions of Harvard and of
universities more generally even in the
age of the online in the virtual an
institution has brought us together and
brings us back we have also son or
rather the Magnificent Renee Fleming his
son America the Beautiful to honor
another institution our Democratic
Republic which the men and women whose
names are carved in stone in Memorial
Church right behind me and Memorial Hall
just behind that gave their lives to
protect and uphold when the founders of
the Massachusetts Bay Colony arrived on
these shores in 1630 they came as
dissenters rejecting institutions of
their English homeland but I've always
found it striking that here in the
wilderness
we're mere survival was the foremost
challenge they so rapidly felt compelled
to found this seat of learning so that
New England in the words of William
Hubbard of the class of 1642 so that New
England might be supplied with persons
fit to manage the affairs of both church
and state Church state and College three
institutions they deemed essential to
this Massachusetts experiment three
institution
to ensure that the colonists as Governor
John Winthrop urged could be knit
together as one in a new society in a
brave new world
dozens of generations have come and gone
since then and the University's
footprint has expanded considerably
beyond a small cluster of wooden
buildings but we have never lost faith
in the capacity of each generation to
build a better society than the one it
was born into we have never lost faith
in the capacity of this College to help
make that possible
as an early founder Thomas Sheppard put
it we hope to graduate into the world
people who are in his words enlarged
toward the country and the good of it
you have now nearly four centuries later
we find ourselves in a challenging
historical moment how do we enlarge our
graduates a new job for the treasurer
how do we enlarge our graduates in a way
that benefits others as well Sheppard
spoke of enlarging toward toward as he
put it the country and the good of it
are we succeeding in educating students
oriented toward the betterment of others
or have we all become so caught up in
individual and personal achievements
opportunities and appearances that we
risk forgetting our interdependence our
responsibilities to one another and to
the institution's meant to promote the
common good this is the era of the
selfie and the selfie stick
now don't get me wrong there's much to
love about selfies and two years ago in
my baccalaureate address I concluded by
urging the graduates to send such
pictures along so that we could keep up
with them in their post Harvard lives
but think for a moment about the
implications of a society that goes
through life taking its own picture that
seems to me a quite literal embodiment
of self regarding a term not often used
as a compliment
in fact merriam-webster dictionary
offers egocentric narcissistic and
selfish as synonyms we direct endless
attention to ourselves our image our
likes just as we are encouraged and in
fact encourage our students to burnish
resumes and fill first college and then
job or graduate school applications with
endless lists of achievements with
examples to borrow Shepards language of
constant enlargements of self as one
social commentator has observed we are
ceaselessly at work building our own
brands we spend time looking at screens
instead of one another large portions of
our lives are hardly experienced they
are curated shared snapchatted and
Instagram rendered as a kind of
composite selfie now a certain amount of
self-absorption
is in our nature as Harvard's own al
Wilson has recently written and I quote
him we are an insatiable curious species
provided the subjects are our personal
selves and people we would know or would
like to know but I want to underscore
two troubling aspects of this obsession
with ourselves the first is it
undermines our sense
of responsibility to others the ethos of
service at the heart of Thomas
Sheppard's phrase describing Harvard's
enduring commitment to graduate students
who are enlarged to be about more than
themselves not just enlarged for their
own sake and betterment but enlarged
toward others and toward the world this
is part of the essence of what this
university has always strived to be our
students and faculty have embodied that
spirit through their work to serve in
our neighborhood and around the world
from tutoring at the Harvard ed portal
in Austin to working in Liberia to
mitigate the Ebola crisis they make a
difference in the lives of countless
individuals the Dexter gate across the
yard invites students to enter to grow
in wisdom depart to serve better by
country and that kind today some 6,500
graduates go forth may each of them
remember that it is in some way to serve
there is yet another danger we should
note as well self-absorption may obscure
not only our responsibilities to others
but our dependence upon them and this is
troubling for Harvard for higher
education and for fundamental social
institutions whose purposes and
necessity we forget at our peril why do
we even need college critics demand
can't we do it all on our own
Peter Thiel Silicon Valley entrepreneur
has urged students to drop out and has
even subsidized them including several
of our undergraduates to leave college
and pursue their individual
entrepreneurial dreams after all the
logic goes Mark Zuckerberg and Bill
Gates dropped out and they seem to have
done
okay well yes but we should remember
Bill Gates and Mark Zuckerberg had
Harvard to drop out of
Harvard Harvard to serve as the place
where their world-changing discoveries
were born Harvard and institutions like
it to train the physicists
mathematicians computer scientists
business analysts lawyers and thousands
of other skilled individuals upon whom
Facebook and Microsoft depend Harvard to
enlighten public servants to lead a
country in which Facebook Microsoft and
companies like them can thrive Harvard
to nurture the writers and filmmakers
and journalists who create the storied
content that gives the Internet its
substance and we must recognize as well
that universities have served as sources
of discoveries essential to the work of
the companies advancing the revolutions
and technology that have changed our
lives from early successes in creating
and programming computers to development
of prototypes that lay groundwork for
the now ubiquitous touchscreen we are
told to that universities are about to
be unbundled disrupted by innovations
that enable individuals to teach
themselves selecting from a buffet of
massive open online courses and building
do-it-yourself degrees but online
opportunities and residential learning
are not at odds the former can
strengthen but does not supplant the
latter and through initiatives like EDX
and Harvard X we are sharing
intellectual riches that are the
creations of institutions of higher
learning sharing them with millions of
people around the globe
intriguingly we have found that a highly
represented group among these online
learners
around the world is teachers who will
use this knowledge to enrich their own
schools and face-to-face classrooms
assertions about the irrelevance of
universities are part of a broader and
growing mistrust of institutions more
generally one fueled by our intoxication
with the power and charisma of the
individual and the cult of celebrity
government business nonprofits are
joined with universities as targets of
suspicion and criticism there are few
countervailing voices to remind us how
institutions serve and support us we
tend to take what they do for granted
your food was safe your blood test was
reliable your polling place was open
electricity was available when you flip
the switch your flight to Boston took
off and landed according to rules and
systems and organizations responsible
for safe air travel just imagine a week
or a month without this civic
infrastructure without the institutions
that undergird our society and without
the commitment to our interdependence
that created these structures of
commonality in the first place
think of the countries in West Africa
that lacked the public health systems to
contain Ebola and the devastation that
resulted contrast that with the network
of institutions that so rapidly saved
lives and contain spread of the disease
when it appeared in the United States
think about other elements of our civic
infrastructure the libraries the museums
the school committees the religious
organizations that are as vital to
moving us forward as are our roads and
railways and bridges
institutions embody our present and
enduring commitments to one another they
bring our disparate talents and
capacities to the pursuit of common
purpose at the same time they link us to
both what has come before and what will
follow
they are repositories of values values
that precede transcend and outlast the
self they challenge us to look beyond
the immediate the instantly gratifying
to think about the bigger picture the
longer run the larger home they remind
us that the world is only temporarily
ours that we are stewards entrusted with
the past and responsible to the future
we are larger than ourselves and our
selfies that responsibility is
quintessentially the work of
universities calling upon our shared
human heritage to invent a new future
the future that will be created by the
thousands of graduates who leave here
today our work is about that ongoing
commitment not to a single individual or
even one generation or one era but to a
larger world and to the service of the
age that is waiting before in 1884 my
predecessor Charles William Elliot
unveiled a statue of John Harvard and
spoke of the good that can come from the
study of what we might call the enlarged
life of the man who's named this
university bears Eliot said he will
teach that the good which men do lives
after them fructified and multiplied
beyond all power of measurement or
computation he will teach that from the
seed which he planted have sprung joy
strength
and energy ever fresh blooming year
after year in this garden of learning
and flourishing as time goes on in all
fields of human activity in other words
that statue we paraded past this
afternoon
is not simply a monument to an
individual but to a community and an
institution constantly renewing itself
your presence here today represents an
act of connection and of affirmation of
that community and of this institution
it's a recognition of Harvard's capacity
to propel you towards lives and worlds
beyond your own I thank you for the
commitment that brought you here today
and for all it means and sustained I
wish you joy strength and energy ever
fresh thank you very much
you